pour en parler nous sommes avec olivier
python auteur de la nouvelle révolution
américaine aux éditions plon bonsoir
olivier py des très beaux ou en direct
sur rt france loyaux qui reporte la
primaire démocrate
on ne va pas comparer avec les
municipales françaises mais est-ce que
ce coronavirus risque quand même de
peser très fortement dans cette campagne
démocrate
premièrement et après peut-être dans la
présidentielle américaine
en fait on a un décalage entre ce qui se
passe en europe et en particulier en
france et ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
d'environ une quinzaine de jours on le
voit avec le nombre de cas de
contamination et le nombre de décès donc
il est assez difficile aujourd'hui de
savoir ce que dans quinze jours ou dans
trois semaines la situation aux états
unis va être ce qui est incontestable
c'est que si on se suit la tendance aux
états unis comme elles semblent se se
dérouler en europe on risque
effectivement d'avoir au moment de la
mise en place des conventions
c'est à dire à l'été les conventions
delluc démocratique par démocrate et
républicaine on risque d'avoir à ce
moment là un certain nombre de problèmes
effectivement avec des états on l'a vu
avec l'ohio qui n'ont pas encore voté et
qui pourraient ne pas voter à ce moment
là et donc on pourrait effectivement
avoir des difficultés
selon vous la les américains n'ont pas
encore pris la pleine mesure de la
gravité de cette épidémie
s'ils ont pris la pleine mesure n'y a
pas eu de phénomène de 2,2 deux derniers
jours avant avant avant incarcération
comme on a eu en france ils sont rentrés
tout de suite dans le jeu del annonce de
l'état d'urgence par donald trump
alors ensuite comme c'est un état
fédéral et donc ce sont 50 états on a
des dispositifs qui sont différents
selon les états par exemple le new
jersey est en état d'urgence avec l'état
de washington et d'autres états ne le
sont pas encore et à l'intérieur des
états certaines villes se sont mis
également en état d'urgence et le cas de
new york ou de los angeles par exemple
qui sont allés plus loin que ce qu'avait
décidé les gouverneurs de leurs états
respectifs
donc on a en tout cas une situation qui
est assez maîtrisé on a eu dans un
premier temps un rush
vers les supermarchés pour se doter d
des provisions les plus les plus
essentiels et là on retourne un petit
peu vers la normale et on a encore une
fois des disparités en fonction de
l'endroit où on habite aux états unis
alors c'est vrai que donald trump à
prayssas pardonnez moi l'expression mais
c'est peu par dessus la jambe
au début un il ironisé un peu sur sept
ce qu'il appelle un peu une grippe où il
donnait des poignées de main un petit
peu facile comment les américains ont
jugé l'attitude de ce président comme
toujours avec donald trump et le
coronavirus ne fait pas exception à la
règle
c'est extrêmement clivant ses supporters
trouvent qu'il prend les bonnes
décisions ne met pas en cause
effectivement le fameux épisode la
poignée de main lors de la conférence de
presse où justement il décrétait l'état
d'urgence
et puis les opposants effectivement
parle de négligence parle de deux
mesures de mesures qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
pour l'instant le taux de contamination
aux états unis est de l'ordre de 200
nouveaux cas par jour
et donc on est dans un trend qui est à
peu près celui de l'europe avec le
retard qui est qui est à peu près de 15
et d'une quinzaine de jours et donc les
gens attendent de savoir si les mesures
qui ont été décidées c'est-à-dire il ya
à la fois des mesures d'ordre sanitaire
mais également des mesures d'ordre
économique vont être efficace aux états
unis alors donald trump qui cherche je
sais pas si l'expression est heureuse ou
quand même à politiser ce virus qu'il
appelle le virus chinois oui d'ailleurs
des correspondants de presse en chine
américains ont été expulsés aujourd'hui
donc on est de toute façon toujours dans
une guerre en tout cas une guerre des
mots entre les états unis la chine donc
c'est la guerre commerciale par d'autres
moyens le corps n'a virus ne fait pas
exception à la règle
en tout cas ça permet à donald trump
d'assumer la fermeture des frontières
puisque c'est un virus étrangers entre
guillemets d'assumer le fait que des
restrictions soient opérés dans
le domaine économique et puis évidemment
de démo de demander le déblocage à
l'échelon fédéral de quelques 850
milliards de dollars en tout cas c'est
ce qui est en discussion actuellement
avec le congrès une dernière petite
question qui concerne le traitement
parce que c'est par là qu'on va s'en
sortir un premier essai clinique d'un
vaccin a eu lieu justement sur 45
personnes aux états unis lundi 16 mars à
ce qu'on en parle beaucoup outre
atlantique et beaucoup d'espérance sur
ce vaccin
non mais en tout cas les américains
espèrent avoir rapidement un accès à ce
vaccin et il espère évidemment parce que
c'est le patriotisme américain qui joue
que ce soit des savons des experts des
médecins américains qui le découvre en
premier de la nouvelle révolution
américaine aux éditions plon d'avoir été
avec nous en dira avec sur rt france